disgraced felon lawyer michael cohen has
a new book out it's an election year
quickie that he probably hasn't even
read it attacks donald trump
someone should ask him have you read it
quick what's chapter three about
no one will ask him that of course the
media naturally have swung into
formation and promote it cnn's leading
the charge tomorrow night michael cohen
is on cnn for a
much hyped prime time interview you can
imagine how many tough questions he's
going to get unseen and probably not too
many
for michael cohen cnn is like a second
home he's got a lot of close friends
over there
including we told you about this last
week the channel's chief bodybuilding
correspondent chris cuomo
well much more on the friendship between
cohen and cuomo later in the week
but chris cuomo is not cohen's only ally
at cnn cohen is also
close to cnn president jeff zucker the
man who moonlights as a democratic
campaign operative
cohen zucker once had kids at the same
private school in new york cohen served
on the board of the school with zucker's
ex-wife
jeff zucker and michael cohen have long
been personal friends at least to the
extent that narcissists have the
capacity
for personal friendship their
relationship tells you a lot about how
things
actually work in media and in politics
case in point
on march 10 2016 that was the day of the
final republican primary debate
cohen called jeff zucker on his cell
phone cnn was hosting the debate that
night in miami and cohen who was working
for donald trump at the time
wanted to check in about it zucker
almost immediately started bragging
about himself as he has wanted to do
after a few pro formal words about their
family zucker launched into an extended
lecture
about his own importance here's the
thing zucker announced to cohen
you cannot be elected president of the
united states without cnn
fox and msnbc are irrelevant irrelevant
in electing a general election candidate
if you want to run the country in other
words jeff zucker said you've got to
sniff my throne
it's not that cnn needs the help he
explained quote we're killing it we're
doing great
but donald trump badly needs cnn quote
you guys have had great instincts great
guts great understanding of everything
but you're missing the boat on how it
works going forward
oh how it works going forward okay
michael cohen replies
why don't you email donald trump and
tell him that
and at that point for the first time in
the conversation
jeff zucker pauses it turns out that
jeff stoker doesn't like to write things
down
sneaky people never do so here's what he
says next
i'm very conscious of not putting too
much in email
as you're a lawyer as you understand and
you know and as fond as i am of the boss
he also has a tendency like you know if
i call him or i
email him he then is capable of going
out in his next rally and saying that we
just talked
and i can't have that if you know what
i'm saying
people would know i talked to trump and
i can't have
that if you know what i'm saying yeah we
know what you're saying jeff zucker
you're saying that secretly when you
think no one is watching you are more
than happy to play
all sides you can brag about how
powerful you are the big time network
honcho king maker
the man who decides who's president like
all tiny insecure people you will mix
flattery with your swagger along the way
you'll refer to donald trump as
the boss even when he's not on the call
you're happy to do that
what you don't want is anyone in your
tiny self-righteous left-wing rich
person world
to know that you're doing it what would
don lamond think if he knew you were
talking to orange satan
brook baldwin might storm off the set
the world would conclude that you're a
dishonest
phony and for good reasons you've got to
keep it all hidden sorry
you know what i'm saying but zucker
assured michael cohen that none of this
was personal quote
it's not that i don't want to talk to
trump every day i've just got to be
careful because
because i've got to be careful i just
don't want him talking about it on the
campaign trail but you know what
i'm going to give him a call right now
and i'm going to wish him luck
in the debate tonight and then zucker
added this
i have all these proposals for him like
i want to do a weekly
you know i i want to do a weekly show
with him and all this stuff when
is he back in new york tomorrow do you
know
wait what a weekly show on cnn
jeff zucker the president of cnn wanted
to give a weekly show to a man he
himself has denounced
as a racist yep that was the plan
trump of course never did get the show
anderson cooper is still there
but jeff zucker did take the time to
dispense quite a bit of
unsolicited political advice to michael
cohen
quote i think the other guys are going
to gang up on him tremendously tonight
sucker said about the debate that night
and i think he's going to hold his own
as he does
every time he's never lost a debate and
you know what he's good at this he's
going to do great
cohen didn't seem convinced by this
cohen was worried about attacks from the
other republicans
on the stage but zucker reassured him
that trump would prevail
and then jeff zucker offered this
surprisingly detailed political advice
listen how many times do you think cruz
is going to call him
a con man tonight no uh rook i mean
rubio i mean rubio
how many times do you think a lot a lot
i i say a hundred
so you know what you know what you
should do is who's ever around him today
should just be calling him a con man all
day
so that he can get so he's used to it so
that when he hears it from
from rubio it doesn't matter
hey con man econ man a con man hey con
man ain't gone man
yeah if you want to get so like you know
yeah you want to get so light in the
head
they think that he thinks that's his
name you know
hey con man hey con man hey con man says
the con man
there it is that's how it really works
inside tips on how to navigate the cnn
debate
from the head of cnn jeff zucker a man
who was supposedly a journalist
secretly working as a political
consultant the guy who runs the
democratic party's most faithful
news network giving political advice to
the republican front runner
donald trump's chief tormentor colluding
secretly
with donald trump's lawyer it's all
bewildering
but that's what it's really like that's
the real
jeff sucker a man who believes in
nothing
a man whose only goal is proximity to
power no matter who wields it
no wonder he's friends with michael
cohen
well we'll have more tomorrow including
tape that we'll explain
how do those cnn interviews come about
some of them seem
coached some of them seem like the guest
knows what the host is going to ask
turns out because that's really what
happens they're coached
and we'll prove it tomorrow night here's
a sample
i think the way this conversation goes
is almost exactly the way we're having
it right now
which is where i say this looks shady
and you say yeah it looks shady to you
because you're coming with a specific
intention but i'm telling you here's why
i did